cyber security is one of the most
important domains in the current times
with businesses moving online and
shifting to cloud storage currently the
demand for cyber security is at its peak
however
many of you might still have second
thoughts when it comes to starting a
career in cyber security here we are to
help you understand why you should learn
cyber security
on that note hey guys welcome to yet
another interesting video by simply loan
in this video we bring you the top 10
reasons to learn cyber security in 2022
but before we begin if you are new here
and haven't subscribed already make sure
you hit the subscribe button and the
bell icon for interesting tech videos
every day
so let's get started
now there are several reasons as to why
you should learn cyber security
here we have the top 10 reasons for the
same
at number 10
the reason we have is basic requirements
there is a wrong notion that building a
career in cyber security is daunting
well it is not
a fancy college degree is not at all
that it takes to become a successful
cyber security professional
you can venture into the domain of cyber
security with some basic knowledge of
i.t and with an authorized cyber
security certification
the overall eligibility criterion for
the cyber security domain is relaxing
across the world
i.t professionals with cyber security
certifications are known to receive
higher salary packages
certifications are always given extra
weightage in the infosec field and it
opens doors to bigger opportunities
these cybersecurity certifications can
be opted by anyone as the eligibility
for these are very basic
cyber security certifications trained
professionals and thus helps in bridging
the gap between the supply and demand of
skilled cyber security professionals
so don't take a step back from learning
cybersecurity thinking it is a tedious
process
if you are a fresher or a professional
you can go ahead with just these basic
requirements
before moving on to our next reason here
is a question for you all
how many of you like mathematics please
let us know in the comment section below
i'm sure not everyone loves mathematics
and that is completely okay when it
comes to learning cybersecurity
and our ninth reason is mathematics is
not a concern for learning cybersecurity
many of us find mathematics challenging
some have the aptitude for dealing with
numbers and some don't
and for those who don't they find it
difficult to proceed with a career that
has maths involved
however you can take your decision
without any worries when it comes to
cyber security as the domain of cyber
security does not involve mathematics
so if maths is not your strong point
then choosing to learn cybersecurity is
a great choice
this can definitely be a relief to many
instead you can get acquainted with
networking network security control and
coding to build a career in cyber
security
our eighth reason is that cyber security
is a profession that helps achieve the
greater good
cyber security consists of a set of
measures and approaches that help
companies and individuals data from
being compromised and stolen
cybersecurity professionals have
defended organizations from several
deadly cyber attacks that aimed at
jeopardizing an organization's
confidentiality integrity and
availability
cyber crimes are currently on the rise
with different types of cyber attacks
the threat to organizations and
individuals alike is only growing by the
day government agencies police forces
and cyber crime cells are tackling this
threat
however there is more requirement for
skilled cyber security professionals who
can protect data and work for the
greater good
therefore
if you want to bring about a positive
impact and a meaningful difference to
the society we live in
then learning cybersecurity is a great
choice
our seventh reason is that you get to
travel the world
who doesn't love to travel the globe
learning cyber security is a great
reason especially for those of you who
aspire to travel the world
with the lack of cyber security
professionals in the world there are
plenty of opportunities for skilled
experts to travel overseas to showcase
the cyber security skills which are in
high demand
the increased demand for cyber security
professionals is not just restricted to
one area but to the entire world
there are several employment
opportunities for cyber security
professionals across the globe so
learning cyber security can open new
doors for you overseas as well
our sixth reason is very interesting and
that is the fact that you get to work
with secret agencies and high profile
ones
like other professionals
cyber security professionals also have
the opportunity to work with several
prestigious multinational companies and
big giants like google dell accenture
and others however
a cyber security professional's career
opportunities can go beyond mncs and
they might get the opportunity to work
with top government secret agencies like
mossad nsa nia fbi and so on so what are
you waiting for
become a cyber security expert and
showcase your skills to grab the chance
to work with these top agencies
our fifth reason is
it is never too late to begin with
there are very few professions that give
you the liberty to begin late
and one such profession is cyber
security it is never too late to realize
that you want to become a cyber security
expert
many people work as cyber security
professionals even after the retirement
if they have a good knowledge about it
you could also join cyber security
courses that train you irrespective of
your age
as long as you have good cyber security
skills there is no need to worry about
job security however late it is
our fourth reason is cybersecurity is an
evergreen industry
cyber security has gradually become an
evergreen industry
in the current times with the onset of
the kovate 19 pandemic businesses are
moving online and shifting to cloud
storage the demand for cyber security is
at its peak
there is a high demand for cyber
security experts who can safeguard
digital data
hence
we can be rest assured that cyber
security is here to stay and this domain
is only going to grow in the coming
years
according to cyber security ventures
the number of internet users will hit a
whopping 6 billion by 2022
these numbers speak volumes and this
reveals the growing demand for cyber
security professionals across the globe
digitalization is taking place across
several industries
a cyber security expert finds
opportunities in every field as every
organization wants to be secure on the
digital front
so now is the right time if you are
looking to learn and start a career in
cyber security before moving to our top
three reasons to learn cyber security
here's some crucial information for you
all
as you know with relevant certifications
you can grow your cyber security career
and here we are to help you with that
you can check out simply learn's cyber
security expert masters program to equip
you with the necessary skills to become
an expert in this rapidly growing domain
training for highly short after
certifications like comptia security
plus ch cism and cissp is at the
forefront of this course preparing you
for the industry's best jobs
so what are you waiting for get
certified with simply learn and grow
your career in cyber security today
so our third reason to learn cyber
security is because of the plenty of job
opportunities it offers
according to the u.s bureau of labor
statistics
the employment of information security
analysts is projected to grow 33 percent
from 2020 to 2030
much faster than the average for all
occupations
with the world turning digital there is
a dire need for companies to hire cyber
security experts who can protect and
safeguard sensitive data
as firms work to improve their cyber
security structure they are also hiring
several cyber security experts to design
implement and maintain their cyber
security solutions
security jobs are not limited to the i.t
domain
many security positions are found at
companies outside of it including
industries like media sports or finance
to name a few
this emphasizes on the fact that a cyber
security export is exposed to several
job opportunities from different types
of companies across the globe
our second reason for you to learn cyber
security is the good salary package it
offers
salaries play a crucial part in any job
that you undertake isn't it
every individual likes to get duly
rewarded for their work and cyber
security is one such domain that
provides fat paychecks
cybersecurity exports are the
individuals who have come to the rescue
with the unprecedented rise in cyber
crimes across the world
organizations are willing to pay
sky-high salaries for these cyber
security exports
there is a lack of skilled cyber
security professionals and this is
another reason cyber security experts
are paid well
the salaries of cyber security
professionals are still expected to grow
in the coming times owing to the high
demand
salaries in cyber security have a high
growth potential and if you are a
skilled cyber security professional you
can always negotiate your salary
finally a top reason to learn cyber
security is that you will have a job
that never gets boring and a domain that
offers unlimited potential for personal
growth
several times individuals find
themselves lost in their career due to
lack of challenges due to their mundane
work and also due to stagnation at work
these reasons play a major role when it
comes to a professional quitting their
job
however a job rule in cyber security
tackles these reasons to an extent
and that is why we have this reason at
number one
cyber security is a domain that is
constantly evolving and so are the
nature of cyber attacks
hackers are always trying to develop new
methods to get to your data
they develop new exploits regularly and
hence as a cyber security professional
you will face interesting challenges to
find optimal solutions for new exploits
you will have new puzzles to solve
a cyber security career is not going to
be stale
along with failures you will also be
exposed to new and interesting
discoveries
to keep yourself updated in this field
and to tackle cyber attacks
you should be in a position to outsmart
the hackers
being in the field of cyber security
allows you to constantly upskill and
enhance your knowledge and experience
it also ensures that your learning
journey will never stop
so with that we have come to the end of
this video on the top 10 reasons to
learn cyber security do you agree with
our list
think if you missed anything important
do let us know in the comment section
below
thank you so much for being here and do
watch out for more videos from us until
then keep learning and stay tuned for
more from simply alone
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here